Mm,
mm.
Welcome everybody.
To the h three soundboard experience had
a lot of complaints about the soundboard
and I hear you most definitely.
Welcome to the soundboard experience
today is we'll return what?
The wonderful,
great,
excellent,
and most beloved video game donkey and
Leah who are currently facing the wall.
I feel like I'm in the Blair witch
project.
Thank you guys.
We are on this side.
Okay.
Welcome everybody.
Thank you guys.
It's very risky.
I liked the you guys.
You don't want to distract me.
You don't want to make it weird if the
wall.
It's very appreciative.
Love that.
Today's episode for free.
Get it sponsored by you to meet honey
and quip.
Welcome back.
Isla,
by the way.
Thank you.
Neil is back in town,
so thankful to have you back.
I have been in the trenches taking
grenades.
How many episodes did they do without
you?
Thank for God or more.
I was gone a month.
Well,
good to have you back.
You didn't get into trouble.
Well,
Leah was just telling me in the last
episode as many of you,
but that's okay.
No,
I got to confront my,
you know,
my shortcomings that I overplayed the
Roseanne sound soundbite.
I didn't see any of that.
What that was.
And now I have one too and I'm going to
be using.
He'll hit me with the cricket.
I've got great news guys.
We're going to be playing another round
today.
Above know your meme.
That's right.
Know your meme featuring the one and
only video game ducky sitting across
from me today.
Soda play call in to eight.
Oh,
eight hot mean.
That is our real number.
Eight.
Oh,
eight hot mean for a chance to win a new
Samsung Galaxy nine plus.
Alright,
are you guys doing great?
Yeah,
we're just enjoying our vacation here.
This is the highlight of the vacation.
I was thinking about hitting you with
Roseanne,
but I get a headache right now.
I'm not going to ride that button.
So what brings you guys out to la?
Well basically they haven't left her
house.
Last time we came out.
Is it a.
it's just to get at,
kind of just get out,
take a trip.
Nice.
See something besides Wisconsin,
like the three blocks around.
Like
what do you,
what goes on in Wisconsin?
Well,
we play tennis.
You do tear up tennis,
tennis.
No real play.
Real tennis or you know,
usually when we don't keep score.
It's just more about getting out there
and exercise.
How frequently do you guys play tennis?
Really?
You know,
if we're doing really good,
we'll go every week.
But you know,
take some breaks.
Sure.
Reeks charge.
But the worse you are at tennis,
the more exercise you want them getting.
We're really,
yeah,
we get a lot done when we do that.
If you guys were like being out here in
La,
I will say by the way,
that Uber that you guys took that we
call it for you take two hours of which
I'm very grateful and sorry for.
Yeah,
it was,
you know,
a relaxing journey.
Stopping and starting
Wisconsin.
Right?
You do.
But I dunno,
I dunno.
It's not have like people on motorcycles
over here going through like the blinds,
Wisconsin.
Like you have like an old grandma,
like driving on the wrong side of the
road.
La driving nuts though,
the cycle between the car has always
struck me as very oddly reckless
behavior.
It is,
but I think when you're on the
motorcycle you feel like you know better
than everyone can do this.
I'm on a fucking motorcycles.
Yeah,
till someone like until that grandma
going the wrong way.
Then all of a sudden
I didn't know.
They scare me man,
because like all the sudden they're
recklessness becomes my problem because
I'm in traffic.
I'm not paying that close attention to
like what's in between me and the next
car.
All of a sudden I'm switching lanes.
No,
we have a word for them in Wisconsin.
She calls them ancient alien.
What?
The motorcycle.
Old People,
old people.
It's anyone who's like,
you know,
and they're driving the wrong way down
the road or they like just stopped in
the middle of ancient aliens.
Old people that just can't see.
And college kids that are just dumb as
hell and mishmash both.
Imagine that you know that guy from h
and alien,
the crazy aliens.
That's who's driving all those cars and
I'm talking about,
well clearly they're like not in this
world right now.
They're like,
this is like,
what do you do?
Have you guys ever been in a car crash?
A,
I have not been in one,
but I wasn't very.
She machine ancient alien thing.
She's been in a lot of accidents stuff.
Maybe she is,
but after seriously never her fault,
but she's always done that.
What was it like?
What happened?
Uh,
one with some lady just went through a
red light and just crushed into one.
That was probably the worst one was.
Yeah,
it was pretty scary.
Are you injured?
No,
we're fine.
What?
Did the car hit?
Your side?
Yeah.
Damn.
Our car didn't get killed though.
They're their card.
Did got maybe what car.
What car were you in?
What car were they in?
Do you remember?
I don't remember.
How old are you?
17 or 16 year survivor.
That's pretty scary to get at a red
light.
That's not a.
that's like a serious.
It was,
you know the back.
Okay.
You spun out maybe.
Probably Shit.
I can't remember anymore.
You blocking it out of your memory suit
from Adam.
What about you?
You've been in a car accident.
I'm just once.
I kinda like I was someone who was
parked like in the middle of the street
so I was going to go wrong with them and
then all of a sudden they started to do
it.
You parked in the middle of the street,
like it was waiting for something
waiting for you so it could hit you,
but it wasn't nothing serious.
It's all good,
but that's it.
My Dad ran.
Someone wants,
my dad is an ancient alien and the eight
he is a liability.
Have we told the story about how in
Mexico,
like my dad is a psycho thought ever get
in a car with them?
Uber driver,
you have like one star driving around
all day and nobody would ever get like,
I don't know what happened.
We were getting off the off ramp and I
was I think in the back seat and he just
rear ended a car.
Just rammed it.
Somebody like you do.
But there was a one time in Mexico,
he's got like an suv and they used to
live in Mexico and he just driving on
the freeway and Mexico like way over the
speed limit so fast that we're taking a
sharp turn and you can feel the tires of
lifting God.
You could feel it being like my mom's in
the car,
I'm in the car dealers in the car.
That's the first time you guys met,
right?
Sort of.
So imagine.
Wow.
Well the story gets better.
Imagine that.
This is how you're behaving around your
son.
First Time you're meeting is serious
partner.
Right?
And we're all yelling.
My mom's going crazy.
We're all yelling.
Gary and Isla,
who doesn't know my dad says he starts
yelling at him.
That's how fucking and meanwhile my dad
is so crazy.
That's there silently doesn't even
acknowledge it continues to rip the
turns.
It's weird.
You like shuts down.
I knew it was fucked up.
I should probably.
Everyone was.
It was scary.
And my dad,
he's,
he's on the road.
He went to Ucla.
I don't know if you guys know about like
college rivalries.
He went to Ucla,
which is University of California.
Their rivals in La is USC.
They're like huge sports rivals,
so his license plate said hates sc and
it's still,
I think,
made to have that license.
So when he sees someone on the road,
what they use,
license plate holder license,
we'll cut them off and I swear to you
with children in the car and the whole
family,
he will cut off another person on the
road with his eighth sea,
like as if they were as if they were
Nazi war sickness.
That's scary.
But I'm sweet guy though.
But anyway.
What are your parents like?
Your parents have any crazy uh,
corks.
Mom is fun.
Oh,
that's a good teacher.
It's crazy.
She's,
you know,
she's uh,
she has guess she has a excuse because
she's a teacher.
That is,
if you're a teacher for like for like
five years,
you're like your mental patient and if
we just keep going,
it's just worse than worse.
What grade does she teach?
Uh,
I think she was teaching second or
third.
Oh Wow.
Let's stop now.
She used to teach middle school or high
school and middle school.
Middle School was way worse.
Scary to me.
In middle school.
High school was really bad.
Middle School's really bad.
Yeah,
and then the greatest second.
That's crazy.
Which one's the craziest?
Middle School or second grade?
I think high school and middle school.
That's like getting into fights.
Yeah.
I feel like middle school's got to be
the worst.
Right?
Dangerous minds.
What's the actress's name and dangerous
minds know that moment,
right?
She was like this,
like pretty young blonde teacher who's
teaching in like the hood that was is
called the poetry one.
There could have been poetry.
Michelle pfeiffer.
Oh,
I did not know that.
It's called.
Oh yeah,
baby.
I love that movie.
Throw that up.
Let me show you what your mom is up to.
Right.
Dangerous minds.
Got It.
I remember watching this as a kid and
being like,
damn,
she's so cool.
She's so cool.
She connects with a trench coat.
I can't really wear trench coats to the
school anymore,
so it's just like real knife in
Wisconsin,
right?
The chalkboard.
We want to die.
Oh Shit.
It's crossed out,
we choose to die to get it straight.
Buster your mum do any lessons like
that,
but I think.
I think middle school is the worst
because they're like
in middle school you're such a piece of
shit and high school you're starting to
learn a little bit.
That's true that you're an idiot.
You're still an idiot.
No.
Yeah.
Full blown,
but it'll cool.
All right.
Jason's mom looks just like him that
well.
He looks like it's.
Oh,
it's cute.
Yeah,
they have the same like mouth and nose.
Kinda pick summit sometime.
So I've got.
I'm trying this new thing.
When we start our podcast,
we're doing this thing called goof for
the day.
I've got some clips lined up.
I don't want to walk through with you
guys.
Okay.
The first one is dj Khaled at performing
at an overwatch league is good.
It's great.
What I love about this is that he's like
dj cows,
not a performer,
right?
It's like the hype man.
So imagine like flavor flave without a
band or anyone to back them up with
actual musical palette.
It's just that stage.
It's crazy.
Here we go.
What does he have?
Oh God bless.
By the way,
you framed this up,
so like there's like 10 people actually
waving their arms and their exit.
Well,
the rest of the room,
it's just like not interested at all.
Let's see.
Just a strange event.
Bam.
It's like Justin Bieber's not.
They're singing that DJ count,
which is the worst part of every music
video.
Oh No.
Or five.
And it's like,
are you serious right now?
That's a good question.
And one more thing.
What it makes it look like,
what?
The phone light.
No,
but you people are holding their phones
up.
They are.
They're making it look like they're
holding their phones up.
No Way.
People have their phones out.
Wristbands probably.
Oh,
maybe like an event wristband.
Yeah.
Looks confused.
You can't do without the rest of the
bank.
You know what I mean?
Like you take out another one is another
word you said plants.
By the way,
these guys were paid to dance.
Did you not even see happening at this
point?
Gala?
No.
Get your own concert.
But like at a concert you,
you think that this could go on for two
hours straight,
but you don't want to appreciate him for
even having the courage to do in this
kind of like,
it really doesn't give a fuck.
But like a blizzard hired him.
Yeah.
It probably paid him like.
I mean,
I don't think he would go out there for
less than $200,000.
Right.
We paid them pretty good
black.
Alright.
You sing it
Keller
good.
That was really good.
What do you think?
You found a decal?
I was out of all the performances,
a blizzard.
That was probably the number one the
most.
But you,
I mean speaking of hip hop,
you are kind of a hip hop musical
performer.
Now your new video came out.
Chicken or chicken wings,
right?
Yup.
I mean people are loving chicken wings.
I love it.
Let me play a sample for those higher
pretty far.
Yeah.
I was loving that by the way.
I'm curious.
Let me just play it for reference.
Did you make this beat?
Yeah.
I made that
serious way.
Really for months on that road.
That beat is insane.
No.
What is it that's just.
You just never heard it.
I don't fucking know you.
I have Kinda kind of subtle.
Damn.
You can just rip is be like that and put
some chicken wings on it.
That's what it is.
Read the description of the video.
Pull it up.
Okay.
You'll see
it's legit.
Thank you.
Wrapping Gambini
for today that I can make this on.
Hashtag no lawsuit.
Can you imagine getting sued for this?
Let me give you a sample of this same
insane.
Rapid.
This is a chicken dishes,
dishes,
the apple.
This is a seller.
I love the backup vocals.
You Officer Drake Salad.
This is electric.
This is your hip hop fan,
right?
Is your favorite genre of music?
What else do you like the star in the R
and b?
Shit.
You are black.
This is my credit card next.
Overwatch
definitely.
I think he would totally correct you and
it.
I mean you elaborated by the way.
I love that
credit card.
Dope.
So good.
You like drake's new album and then.
Oh,
you don't fuck with drag.
I listened to probably like two albums
in the whole year.
Really?
So you don't listen to that much music.
Last time he told me if I recall season
to Israel and to really.
What are you really into right now?
Uh,
stevie wonder.
Hey,
crazy.
What else?
Uh,
just,
just stevie Michael Jackson.
He's gonna.
Try to go see some guy.
Oh yeah.
That one guy.
Kamasi Washington.
You hear him yell,
Saxophone Player.
Can you find a clip of that dinner in?
I want to hear it right now.
Cool.
Kamasi Washington.
I don't know if that's how you say it.
I've got another clip lined up.
I love Stevie,
but like have you.
How long have you been listening to
Stevie?
Or did you just kind of get into it?
So you,
you've been riding the Stevie and
Michael trend for a long time.
Do you share his musical tastes
well?
Yeah,
because he controls
horse musical taste.
If you had control of the cds,
what would you play?
I have one CD.
Where's his six?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I tend to just listen to like whenever
it comes on,
like the student radio or something like
kind of different like all the time.
So I mean if I had to say all time
favorites.
Actually I really like Lana del Rey,
which is like I'm familiar.
I know I really liked her.
She one of the ones that,
was she one of the ones that died or
something like people are like,
she's like a recent pop artist.
Yeah.
That's kind of the only like pop like
thing.
Listen to you.
I listened to a lot of nineties music.
I guess it bird radio station.
I remember that.
Yes.
There's a radio station that plays bird.
Nice.
What's it called?
Talking about like,
uh Oh,
cancer.
The leading killers of birds.
Cats are the leading.
There's a lot of birdwatchers and what's
actually.
I've heard that,
that like that's funny.
Like cats are actually decimating the
populations really.
I guess what do we do?
You know,
if bird radio gets affected,
here's this,
here's this music that the use interior.
Let's see what we got.
If you write anything really,
really,
and I'm ad block
got ad block on their Internet explorer,
you,
you opened it with Internet explorer.
It looks like it's set to default.
Like Gimme a break.
I'm using discord and I click a link.
In what world would I want to open?
Anything in internet explorer?
You see it's a total disaster.
You know,
our sponsors pay us a lot of money to
get their ads on our show and here.
Sneak right?
They didn't pay me shit.
Don't download that.
Download.
Not speak of it off the screen.
In fact,
I'm gonna.
Build them on the invoice.
Then you invoice them for me.
I'm going to say their name.
You're seeing this guy in concert.
This is your guy.
What's his name?
Kamasi Washington.
What's going on with him?
He looked very like Bohemian.
He's cool with that.
Actually.
I interviewed him a couple of years ago.
I shot an interview with him.
Yeah,
he was really cool.
Was the.
Was it an interesting interview?
Yeah.
It was just talking about his musical
background and everything.
He's,
you know,
he comes from like the jazz world,
but you kind of crossed over with all of
the um,
brain feeder,
you know,
like Flying Lotus and those people.
No,
he's,
he's cool as fuck.
So you say he put his part of that role
under cat and all those guys
sick.
Sounds good.
You're all about you like that soul,
that soul music.
Did you know?
Hey Janice.
I like it when they pick on it.
Stress.
Do you hate this stress?
I'll take the same level for me.
I got another video lined up,
another good for the day because I
couldn't decide between Dj Khaled and
all of the Mexican workers going on
strike and this guy filming it and
losing his mind about it.
Okay.
Good stuff.
Planned up guys.
Only the best.
Let me go get fucked up.
They sit on a come together yet.
So let,
don't know anything about who filmed
the story is that they're on some kind
of smelting plant.
Two of the dudes,
I guess their boss supervises our
comrades,
was all of a sudden rush of Soviet
Russia.
Their colleagues got fired or sent home
for some reason,
so they all packed up and said,
fuck this,
you know,
salt,
solidarity.
So this guy who was working with,
I guess there's a bunch of Mexicans and
a couple of black dudes.
So this is one of the black dudes who's
an og of the Mexican camaraderie and
spirit.
They up this book.
Fucking black people need to be your own
man.
I swear to God.
I think they sit up.
Isn't this motherfucking on my momma?
They are not bullshit.
They don't stop up in depth.
They thought they was going to play with
these amigos.
We rise together,
homey.
It may not take the same.
And look at this man.
They shut this big day on today.
We all went home,
man.
The Way God bless him.
I mean jokes aside for documenting that.
I'm with him,
dude.
That's cool.
It's probably going to get in trouble.
Oh yeah,
he's fired.
I'll never work again.
I love it that I'm with them.
I'm in solidarity,
but we need.
Why the hell do you think apple is worth
a trillion dollars?
No unions.
They don't have unions in China,
I don't think.
What do you guys think about apple being
worth a trillion fucking dollars?
Why are you an apple man?
No,
I am.
I found though.
I guess so you're sort of,
you're in your foot,
your foot's in the water.
You like apple?
We don't really have an opinion on it.
I guess it's very.
And we would have to look more into it.
I don't want to take any,
you know,
radical fucking hate bad.
I'm using it very sparingly.
Waiting for the right you can use that
sucks.
And I don't understand like have all
come.
You can keep it of all companies in the
world.
How is it that apple was the one that
got a trillion?
I mean,
what are they doing?
So they just.
Yeah,
they're the most valued company of all
time.
The first company ever to be worth a
trillion dollars.
I mean they sell shit so they aren't
getting or many fucking phones.
Are they selling?
I get it though because everyone's
obsessed with that iphone all over the
word and there were computers too,
so it's like,
yeah,
I get it.
It's expensive to like,
how the hell do people afford that shit?
But that means to me that like the
margins are insane,
that they probably are exploiting hell
of people for those margins to be so
insane.
You know what I'm saying?
Like for someone to make a million
dollars is hard enough,
you have to like step on a couple
throats along the way to make forget
about a billion,
a billion.
There's a couple of hookers in,
in your pool,
under your pool,
whatever.
At least several hundred immoral things
happening.
Yeah.
Is Not being followed.
Apple is notorious,
but it's not just them inside in big,
big.
Like I was watching CNN,
they're doing this whole clip about
like,
God,
I just outed myself for watching CNN.
So,
uh,
anyway,
they're doing this whole thing about
like celebrating that apple made a
trillion dollars and it's like
celebrating.
Yeah,
they've done this whole thing about.
They were talking about it in a very
glorious way.
It wasn't like they were doing party
poppers and shit.
They had like a counter on the wall,
the live stream.
But like,
I don't know what's the exact figure.
But they have evaded so much money.
Tank taxes.
Yeah.
Like how many?
A trillion dollars.
How many Chinese?
Like,
I mean do it.
That's just Chinese.
Lots of Chinese people going down for
those phones.
I don't know what to say,
man.
Lots of Chinese people are going down
for those faults,
but it's okay because they're Chinese.
You got to get really quiet.
Really quiet.
You're going to hit me with the
crickets.
I'm trying to carry on.
You were educating us.
We're newcomers
to the apple trillion dollar industry.
What?
Crickets.
I only needed one thing button there.
I'm curious.
You guys ever work like a normal ass
job?
Yeah.
What'd you do before you were the
sweetheart of Youtube?
Worked at a nursing home.
Seriously?
From my aunt.
What was your day to day?
Uh,
do stuff on the computer and like take
old people to their employee
builder.
They're like,
push them around.
You ever do any dirty work?
Well you're not supposed to,
but like eventually you have to do
because it's just like so much stuff to
deal with and there's not enough people
in.
Oh Wow.
So it was fairly stressful.
I can like,
I want to go on my chair and I was like,
don't touch old people.
You're going to break their back if
you'd fucking touch a metal,
but the.
Then they start getting into by himself.
No,
you can't do that.
I'll support guy.
The craziest thing that happened to you,
how long did you work there?
Uh Huh.
Probably more than a little more than a
year.
What was the craziest
thing that,
that you saw there?
One time I heard a lady,
she was like,
she would only.
She can only say like one thing,
she was like,
Oh hey,
something.
I forget what she says.
She says like the name Markish Hello
Markus.
And I could like just here,
like one time I was walking and I could
just hear like really?
I'm like,
what the fuck?
I opened the up the elevator and she's
just sitting in there by herself.
Hello mark.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
She was like,
yeah,
elevator.
Oh my God.
Hello Markus.
Such such a hard job.
That's kind of sad machine.
They're
probably not that nine days to put her
in elevators.
Just does whatever the fuck it wants.
You ever have somebody.
Did you ever take a diaper or anything?
That gnarly.
Okay.
Other people,
trained professionals.
Bart station,
nurse gun.
That's a tough thing to change it.
That a girl like a damn.
That's a thankless job.
Yeah.
Like that takes a lot of compassion to
take up human shit out of a diaper.
Not a chat.
Not your own child.
A hard.
You didn't take any shit out of luck?
No,
I was,
I had probably the easiest job in that
whole building and you know,
it was pretty stressful environment.
What about Yulia?
I had a few things like,
well since high school I had worked at
like a convenience store.
Basically it was technically a op,
but like they just sell a lot of like
food and snacks and stuff and I don't
know,
I worked there on and off for like four
years I guess,
but just I would like go like to college
and stuff for the semester and come back
and work.
So it wasn't like full time member but
yeah.
And then uh,
the most recent job I had was at a
bakery patisserie actually I was just
like in the front,
sometimes I would help with like
decorating stuff or whatever they needed
help but not really.
It was like a French one that I have a
degree in French.
So it was like,
yeah.
Yeah.
So like I didn't have like a,
you know,
any kind of job to do with that.
So that was kinda like they were
customers who would like speak French
with me and like the pastry chef spoke
French and stuff so I was just kinda
like,
you know,
that's Kinda how I got into that.
Do you still work or are you guys.
No,
I'm well I've run in the online stores
and depth and all that.
How,
how,
how recently were you doing that bakery
job?
When was it?
It was pretty recent that you had like a
date would have been?
It would have been the winter before
last winter.
Yeah.
And the only reason I quit was because
they shut it down.
They were like,
yeah,
it was so weird.
They didn't tell us anything leading up
to like shutting it down.
They were just like,
we're going to have a staff meeting on
Friday like everyone else to come,
and then he was like,
so actually it's shut down and
yeah.
Then you know to a break when we come
back,
we've got no your man coming.
It's going to be insane.
Delco away.
That's right.
Good job on that.
See you guys soon.
Thank you to you.
To me for sponsoring this episode,
that h street podcast guys,
that Matrix is no longer a fantasy
because with you,
to me,
we are plugged right?
The FN.
Okay.
These guys are the largest learning
marketplace.
They've got courses,
really excellent courses on everything
from comic book drawing to programming,
professional fields,
whatever you can dream of.
They've got courses for it.
You don't need to go to college and drop
$100,000
anymore.
You don't have to show up at 8:00
AM with a bunch of people.
You don't like to learn from somebody
that doesn't want to teach.
You do it at your own time,
at your own pace,
the same level of learning even better
because you can pause it and continue
another time when you actually want to
learn.
You don't have to sit in a class for
three hours.
Yes,
I didn't like college.
It was up to me.
I'd go back in time and do you to me
cost me a heck of a lot less than I
probably would be a lot smarter to you
about over 65,000
courses match that.
I went.
I wanted to learn a little bit about
raising this music production software.
They've got this guy teaching me
courses.
They got a whole syllabus,
video,
even those q and a's to help you
navigate.
If you have a question,
you can drop a line to the professor.
What more do you need?
They've got this cool ass thing to the
transcription of the video.
If you want to find a specific place in
a video,
you can search through the spoken video
and find the right spot.
Oh,
I can't do that during a lecture.
I guess they'll just fail this test.
Guess what,
there's no tests because you're learning
because you want to
ever heard of that called learning
because you want to.
Yeah,
that's what,
and he's all about go to u,
D,
e.my/h
through right now and get 90 percent
off.
Are you kidding me?
When did did a university ever offered
me 90 percent off.
Save $80,000
today.
When you sign up for classes,
you will not find a better price.
So sign up for classes right now using
my link u,
d,
e.my/h
three and get access to life changing
classes for 90 percent off and make sure
you download their app for your phone so
you can stream your studies wherever you
are.
That's you.
D,
e dot m y slash h three d.my/h.
three guys give them a shot.
Ninety percent off.
You got nothing to lose except
knowledge,
which you need a lot of.
Go learn.
You hear the angels singing.
What is it that's on their breath?
That's right,
honey.
This has got to be one of the greatest
plugin inventions of all time.
You plug it in,
right,
and with
a couple of clicks and it automatically
searches the entire web for coupons as
you shop.
It's saved me hundreds of dollars and
youtube we'll.
I mean,
for example,
I just going and buying shoes.
I was ready to drop $300.
That was the price.
All of a sudden honey pops in like
Batman and hand and they're like,
oh,
by the way,
we found a coupon code.
You just saved 50 bucks that you didn't
think you were going to save until right
now.
What?
You're probably wondering how much money
can hunt?
He really saved me.
They actually crunched the numbers.
It turns out those of you who have
already downloaded honey for my link
have already collectively saved over
$102,000
in the past few months as an average of
$25 per person.
What?
That's insane.
That is insane.
You may also be thinking of honey
doesn't work on sites that I shop at.
The truth is,
honey works on over 30,000
sites including Amazon,
Ebay,
new egg,
razor,
Walmart,
and more.
So the more and 30,000
more Isla and one more today.
Then you'll find out one more.
Oh,
so the big question is,
how is money?
How was honey free?
Well,
there's no catchall.
Honey gets a small commission from sites
where honey saves you money so it's
always free and that's really all there
is to it.
They hook people up and people in short,
10 million people trust and use honey
and save money all the fricking time.
Here's a little treat for you guys.
We actually teamed up with height,
so if you install it for free with two
clicks using our lake,
join honey.com/
[inaudible].
If you head on over to teddy fresh
within the next week,
you're going to save 15 percent off your
purchase at checkout.
Baum.
That's the power of honey.
You hear that?
Exactly.
So as I said,
head on over to join honey.com/h
three to save 15 percent off teddy fresh
and to save tons of money everywhere
else on the Internet.
I cannot endorse them enough.
I love them.
They're great.
Get honey for free right
now@jointhoney.com
slash [inaudible].
That's [inaudible] dot com slash h
three.
You hear that?
That's God's minding the unbelievers who
haven't yet used quip against all of my
advice,
all of my pleading.
If you have not used quip,
if you have not treated yourself to this
great,
wonderful invention that I love,
this is going to be you being struck
down by lightening,
by God's wrath.
Lightening coming out.
Quit is just essential,
my friends.
It's changed everything you know about
oral hygiene and trust me,
you know very little and you don't need
to know much because this is all unique.
This incredible vibrating toothbrush
starts at just $25.
Wow.
Compared to other electric toothbrushes
or the size of a car battery that
started probably like at least 10,000,
maybe not that much,
but like a couple of hundred bucks.
You don't need all that because in this
little cylinder is a vibrating little
motor that's going to keep your teeth
clean and your breath smelling fresh.
Here's what it does.
First of all,
let's not get ahead of ourselves because
it's got these soft,
incredible bristles.
I hate when the bristle is too hard or
too long and they irritate your gums
because guess what guys?
You can get your teeth worked on,
but gums don't grow back
and that should horrify you.
Gums,
don't grow back true.
You need a good toothbrush or you have
so much problems ahead for you.
So much,
dude,
this toothbrush,
this quip is everything.
Soft bristles.
You turn on the vibration,
it's three minutes of brushing.
Boom,
buck 50 on one side,
buck 50 on their side.
It vibrates impulses to let you know
when to switch sides.
It basically encourages you times you
out without you thinking to give
yourself the perfect brush.
If you're not using this idol,
I can't help you anymore than I love
this thing and I'm telling you it's
going to change everything you know.
Quip
starts@twentyfivedollarsandifyougotogetquip.com
slash h through right now,
you'll get your first refill pack free
with the quip electric toothbrush.
That means that the head pops right off
every three months.
You pop a new head on,
you're good to go.
That's your first refill.
Pack free at [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible],
spelled g t U Qui P.com/h
three.
Trust me on this one guys,
get quip.
Welcome back everybody to another
episode of know your me got a very
special episode because our guests,
that feature is one of the same.
That is right video game.
Donkey sits with me.
Today is going to be the subject of know
your meme.
How does that feel?
Do you feel to be a part of the fender,
so to be on this?
Thank you.
This is probably the best thing in my
life.
That's great.
We'd love to hear that glove here.
That's excellent.
Thank you so much.
It's really hard for me to house Dj.
You got it.
You got one.
Help me on this.
I'm gonna.
Stick to it.
We're going to do this.
We're going to get this right.
Okay.
Crickets on that.
This is the one I'm really excited
about.
I want to do like this or you hit the
left track and it stopped really fast.
Oh yeah.
Know your meme.
That's right.
Let's go to our first caller.
Oh,
thank you Dan.
Appreciate that.
Steve is on the line.
Steve.
Hello and welcome to know your name.
You're on the air.
Hello.
How are you doing?
Hey Stephen.
Where are you from?
Who are you?
Anyway?
I'm from New Jersey.
Um,
you know,
just a,
just a boy out there trying to live.
Absolutely.
We know that.
So,
so.
So Steven,
tell me,
are you a fan of video game donkey?
I am.
I'm a big fan and I'm a little nervous
if I could pick up pool.
Well,
you passed our screening test.
Uh,
Ian,
our intern gave you,
he endorsed you greatly.
And so with that being said,
I think you are ready to play.
No.
Your main.
All right,
go the tents.
Music is beginning.
Stephen Music he put together.
What is donkeys?
Favorite video game?
Is it a mario?
60 four B book Worm Adventures Deluxe,
or see Aka Rena of time.
Steven.
Wow.
Take a moment.
I thought it would have been,
I thought it would have been next to for
Super Mario Brothers too,
but those are not receiving what?
What were the options again?
One.
One more.
We've got a Mario Sixty four b book worm
adventures deluxe or see arena of time.
Well with or is we're going to go into
promoters.
Was that Super Mario?
Sixty four.
Super Mario.
Sixty four and the answer is it was neck
to.
You'll lose.
It wasn't.
It was actually Mario Sixty four.
So Eh Donkey.
I would have guessed all Corrina of
time,
but that would have been wrong,
but it's mario 64 through and through.
I guess your answer basically any Mario
game is the middle on this one question
stuff one,
but you did?
Yeah.
Even.
Well Steven,
let's move it onto question two.
You're on the board.
You've got one point.
How you feeling?
Good.
I'm feeling good.
I'm ready to go.
All right.
Bring it to the tense.
What is video game?
Donkeys.
Favorite dish.
Is it a spaghetti and meatballs?
Spaghetti and meatballs.
Now,
Steven,
I haven't finished choices.
Do you want me to continue with the
choices or you really want to lock that
in?
Good music.
Good.
Again,
a little cocky here,
Stephen.
All right,
I'm going to lock you in.
You don't get the rest.
So you just wanted to say it.
People here,
like is it a spaghetti and meatballs?
Tacos or see pizza?
Getting me a little nervous.
Maybe it's deeper than the me.
Maybe it's maybe it's not spaghetti and
meat balls.
Well,
Steven,
you wouldn't be.
Yeah,
there's other options than,
hey,
I'm going to stick with.
My answer was to Gideon pupils.
Even after you saw how they pushed back
on me as I drive by for the tension.
Is it spaghetti and meat balls?
Oh Shit.
A man of few words.
What is the real answer?
It was tacos the whole time.
He's a public knowledge.
We keep your Super Fan.
You may know that you made.
You look like a Taco guy.
What do you like on your Tacos?
What kind of Tacos you like,
Kelly about your dream talk.
Okay.
We're going to have some ground beef and
there some lettuce cheese.
Oh,
well then I'm going to put some salsa
and Uhm,
what kind of salsa?
Some fresh salsa.
Sour cream guacamole on.
Okay.
What is your favorite fruit is tacos?
Why don't we just buy Mexican Food for
dinner?
Just like you're here in California.
You know what I'm saying?
There are Mexican place.
Do you usually just eat Mexican food
when you're here?
Because you love Mexican food.
You,
you fucking Burrito since you've been
here.
This is really.
He loves the old standby.
She likes chips in the beans and every
breakfast.
Nachos and Keith.
This,
you know what I do though?
I have a twist.
I asked them to put the chips on the
side because I don't like when they get
so soggy.
Never ordered delivery.
Nachos up fool.
You know what I mean?
There's nothing sadder than a socking
soggy Nachos.
Right?
Steven,
can I get an amen?
Thank you.
Does that for me or for me?
Isn't it just a general cricket?
Thank you.
Let's just get Mexican food.
Do you fuck with any other Mexican
dishes back to the game?
Well,
hold on a sec.
We're excited about something before you
eat.
Would you fuck with Burritos,
ideas,
you?
You're talking strictly.
I'd do it on your Mexican food.
Number one cuisine.
Why don't you guys live in la?
You're Mexican food boy.
I've been to Mexico to go see them.
What's your favorite cuisine?
Oh man,
that's a tough one.
Honestly,
my answer is Tacos.
Just say no,
you're right.
Exactly.
You got to get through the layers here.
Do you find it to be do like me posed
steven.
You're know.
I don't love it,
but not really.
No,
it's really.
It's an overhead dish.
It's really on the chef.
You know,
you gotta.
You gotta.
Bring that spice.
Bring that a little right there with Ya.
We're all.
We're all right there with.
All right,
so what are we at?
We have one point on the board.
Keeps going.
Yeah,
we've got to make that sound.
So Steven,
let's go back to the.
We got one point.
We got one strike.
Not The word lifeline.
Well he's got three tries to get two
more.
Okay.
He doesn't have a lifeline,
but chances are he's going to win this
phone.
You know what I mean?
We'd like to do favors,
but if you,
if you miss all of them,
there's not much I can do it for you.
I mean,
I assume that you want this brand new
galaxy s nine plus is a thousand dollar
phone topical line.
You want this?
It is the best phone on the market and a
Samsung.
Wow.
What a great company.
Loved them a lot.
Jason looks like he wants one.
Do you want this?
I get him.
If he gets it,
that's the deal.
That's the real deal.
Statements.
You not rising.
Question number three,
what race is donkey?
A Puerto Rican.
Be Black or to see what it all comes
down to this.
That's not true.
You have 10 seconds to go beyond the
meeting.
Right?
And second,
the meme is black.
I'll let you know what.
Take your time.
You're.
I see her in it.
I want to hear your thought process.
Puerto Rican,
black or white.
Well,
my thought processes is a meme is black.
So,
so,
so the Nemea answered to answer black,
right?
Um,
and to be honest,
if it could just be honest,
I kind of,
I did think that you were black,
white,
whatever.
I totally was disappointed.
A little disappointed if I'm being
honest.
When I found out who was a white guy.
Yeah.
So I don't know if I should answer white
or black.
Well,
no,
I'm not looking for a real answer.
Yeah,
it's not a I,
I would have to go quite wrong.
Gimme a boom.
The real answer.
A black obviously do not have eyes.
He's a black man.
No,
actually the real answer is Puerto
Rican.
No.
Oh boy.
It's white.
You are right.
You are correct.
You have two points that you were on the
board.
You are looking really good.
That was a tough one.
Yeah.
That had me stressing.
I wasn't sure what the answer was and
I've answered in front of me like shit.
A lot of soul music.
Alright.
These last two are honestly so easy.
If you get the.
If you get no,
here we go.
Let me,
let me,
let me play the music now.
Here we go.
What game did donkey get?
Famous playing that later band him and
has since rapidly declined in popularity
to almost complete obscurity a game no
one cares about or plays today.
What is the name of that awful forgotten
gay and that is fallen off the face of
the planet and has basically zero
players.
What is the name of that game?
Is there an ABC choice?
There is.
There is a CS.
Go a B League of legends.
It's almost as if I forgot the name of
it or see Dota two.
We've got to get to the bed though.
I'm ready for it.
What'd you say?
League of legends.
Yes.
I feel like I'm trying to League of
legends.
It's almost as if I barely,
you know,
in a way it's like who like.
Do people still play that game though?
I mean seriously.
Yeah.
Only in like China,
right?
Well they didn't even have like Dj
Khaled come in anymore.
Right.
Overwatch got DJ count money now.
But like you used to be known for
playing league,
but now I feel like that's ancient
history.
Like isn't that feel good that you got
away from that kind of videos?
It was a big change.
Was that,
I mean,
were you thinking about getting away
from making those kinds of videos for a
long time or was it just like they were
dicks and you fucked off kind of like a
rash decision,
but it was first basket area.
He was just like,
I was really scared that he was going to
like,
regret drastic change right away,
but he is just like,
well,
I was scared.
Is like,
well there was a bunch of people who
were making league videos,
but that's kind of like a dead thing
now,
isn't it?
It wasn't really like it's on the
downhill,
but it's still stolen.
Rises,
continues to rise.
By the way,
Stephen,
congratulations to you.
We don't even need to read the fifth
question,
which frankly isn't really a good
question.
Anyone three?
Yeah.
You're a winner one.
This brand new Samsung Galaxy s nine
plus.
What phone are you currently?
Uh,
I'm using an iphone and it doesn't work
very well up.
Oh yeah.
Mash.
That thing was to send us back the
cement you sent back to match,
but I've heard.
No,
I'm kidding.
Thank you for calling in.
Stephen.
Thank you for playing.
Thank you for being a great contestant,
a sewer of donkey mythology.
Thank you so much.
Make sure you stay on the line.
Right.
Love it.
I was talking with you guys before.
Know your man,
which by the way,
so much fun.
That was scary for a minute.
You know you're still on the line.
Jesus.
God,
You keep messing with this guy for
Steven.
We had liked that.
Fun here.
Like that.
Okay.
Guys at the ice cream,
you know,
they keep giving you an ice cube.
And then the flip side,
at what point
do you just walk away from that
situation?
Because it is pretty familiar.
I would have probably left daily.
Well,
not from this.
No,
but I'm talking about,
you know,
let me a street vendor like trick I
guess,
but I think you know what you're getting
into.
What would you call that?
Ice Cream prankster scream like street,
like trash thing.
It's always like talking about really
got to fight,
scream trick.
Like an ice cream truck guy.
His truck people.
Dude,
this shit's crazy.
Oh yeah.
Lots of ideas,
by the way,
I don't want that cone for my pants.
You know what I'm saying?
Like Shit,
you know,
I don't know.
Oh Nice.
He's going to get it for real.
You're loading it up.
Loaded up.
Idiot.
The best act ever pulled it away that
this poor guy,
by the way,
by the time he gets to eat it,
it's been in his pocket.
It's been on stage.
It's like I don't want that ice cream.
First one I've seen where they smeared
it on it.
So in short,
that's what.
That's how what we did initially.
Yeah,
that is.
I'm trying to be annoying but funny.
Got To love those ice cream gentlemen in
a parallel universe.
But do you think you could pull that
off?
I feel like you're a gentleman and I
carola universe that we're talking about
dinner.
I didn't know.
You're so passionate about Mexican food.
I'm very passionate about Mexican food.
Yeah,
your Taco,
Taco master.
He knows how to make really good salsa.
Yeah,
Dude.
Nobody.
Nobody knows that that's like a.
that's like a desired skill among shit.
Well,
I.
So I have one specific salsa.
I'm very good at the red and all this
mystery stuff.
I'm not very good at,
but I make a great avocado green salsa.
That is excellent.
But I'm.
I'm thinking we should just hoarder.
Yeah,
I'm saying get some Nachos.
You can't order Nachos?
No,
don't order not just to get them to the
chip.
Separate Nachos with chips separate.
That'd be kind of making order,
but I was just talking about how this
morning I'm so tired.
I woke up because I've been preparing
for you guys just visit last time we
were here,
we had we cooked dinner.
It was so much fun.
Amazing chef cooked us up to the
current.
You guys were loving it.
It sounds like that's less.
I made it so fun.
Cooking for people who are appreciative.
I was like,
damn,
I'm going to pull all the stops for
these guys.
So I was thinking,
well,
I woke up at 5:00
AM this morning.
I bake chocolate chip cookies,
only smoke up your ass.
These aren't saying he's so good and I
was going to bring some for the guy,
the guys,
Dan,
but I was like not enough cookies for
honestly,
and I bring that up just to make them
feel that I bring that up because I want
you to know that you guys are so cookie.
Sorry.
I'm sorry,
but the new thing I'm working on is
baking.
I'm working on learning how to make
sourdough bread.
Tell me about that and it's like it's so
intense and it's so time consuming,
but it's a good starter.
I made my own starter from scratch.
I think it's in a good shape,
really good bread and last Friday it was
like professional.
While I had made two breads.
One was great,
one was like perfect.
The first one,
the second one was a literal brick,
but still it was like you could break.
The flavor was good.
As far as breaks go,
pretty important.
Structure was off,
so I can't wait.
I started getting that starter.
She's my favorite food.
I did.
Anyway.
I rolled the dough.
I proved it,
proved it some more.
It's in the proven basket now.
It's in the fridge.
I've got it.
Actually this one I'm super proud of
because the um,
the starter was bubbly and ice crash.
It was like really good smell and
texture and this morning I was kneading
the dough and it was just looking really
good.
And so I did a little twist because I
didn't want to over prove it by the way.
Proving people don't know is when you
leave the dough out for several hours
and the yeast eats the flower so it
starts to rise and make it fluffy and
turn.
It's our team does all the magic.
So you prove it,
but I didn't want to over prove it.
So I popped it in the fridge.
That's the twist.
I don't know if it's going to work,
but it should.
I'm not going to work if I buy into that
and it's terrible.
I'm to,
I'm going to feel horrible knowing the
slider.
I really liked those.
So wholesome because Isla is the
pickiest eater ever.
She loves bread and the bread here in
America is so bad.
I have no problem with them.
Bread here?
Yeah.
Noticed
and define Brenda.
She'll just eat a role,
but.
So yeah,
I will just eat plain know the baker I
worked out was also a sourdough bakery.
Specifically salary.
No.
Nice.
Yeah,
so I got a lot of free bread there.
Thing that,
that we particularly hate.
Isla is that there's so much sugar.
Like if you go to the store,
bakeries have got it going on generally
like in a good way,
but at the store it's like I've noticed
you'll get a hot dog bun and it's got
six grams of sugar in it.
Yeah,
that's true.
I don't know.
We try to buy like local bakeries.
That's.
Yeah.
We don't really have a baker in Paris.
So you guys are on the.
You guys are killing it on breads.
We try to go to the grocery store.
They don't even have like local bake,
like bakery stuff at your grocery store.
So they always.
They're always dry.
Yeah.
Browse like Ralph's make their own bread
and it's like,
you know,
the rouse lady,
she doesn't really care what's going on
at that level.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like the bakery fresh,
not like artisan.
They're fucking around back there.
They don't take.
They don't take it on the ceiling.
Don't take it.
You know what I'm doing?
I've got oil on my hands so it doesn't
stick.
I'm neat.
I've needed this dough.
I don't think they're doing that.
Definitely not doing that.
So it's so much.
Sun is coming up.
I'm in the kitchen on wedding oil,
on my hands.
I need sleeping.
I'll wake up upstairs.
I'm downstairs sweating.
Needed oil on my hands.
You know what I'm saying?
How come this is a very unusual.
It unusual because I knew you guys were
coming and I want it to.
I'm wanting to do the right thing,
but the question is now
and I've learned that you were such a
Mexican food fanatic,
which I appreciate so much is because I
was originally planning to cook some
filet minions and all my.
I'm going to give you the option.
I think
probably just follow up with my follow
up.
You got a couple of Chubby.
This is good edge.
Uh,
you guys can have a side conversation.
Me and Jason could talk all day about
this kind of Hokey.
Like my bread,
because you see,
it seems like you're in deep in the
bread world,
so this is going to be a real test for
me.
I'm going to eat it plain.
I'm going to eat it with butter.
Wow.
Nutella we're prepared.
You're not.
We bought,
we bought,
we bought butter.
Salted,
of course.
French.
Very nice.
And Jelly cream cheese obviously.
Yeah.
I don't usually have cream cheese on it.
What's a killer one?
Cream cheese and jelly sandwich.
That's right.
It's really good.
So back to the meats because the bread
was Scott sorta started dinner and no,
we're one course down.
Don't jump the gun.
So I think that my specialty is
definitely cooking steaks so I can do
that.
But also,
I mean Mexican food teco wrongs steak
Tacos.
You can vary.
Yeah,
you can vary.
Go wrong.
There's a lot of bad places.
So if we order there's a chance it's
going to be bad.
It's probably going to be good to ask
because I'm Mexican food in Wisconsin.
I can't be that.
Is there a good Mexican food and there's
some good people out there.
Are they Mexican cooking?
Okay.
They produce is not as good.
That said,
no,
Dan,
are you speaking from Mexican food and
Wisconsin and I might be speaking out of
turn because I've never been to
Wisconsin,
but probably not.
By the way,
I like the urgency of you to send me a
DM.
No private life about Mexican food.
So why don't we do both?
Sometime we should do both.
That'd be a fun,
interesting video almost.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
If people are listening to this,
if anybody's left lists,
they're going to love that one on the
best videos was made a really great
video about like Burrito density.
Did you see?
That was so good.
He made a video analyzing the content of
Burritos in San Diego and it was so
fucking great.
Opens up the brooders and analyzes.
So good.
Yeah.
The dedication,
the conclusion.
Well he was analyzing like three
different major chains and like if
they're making them right because
sometimes,
believe it or not,
they put French fries,
embryos,
and just kind of a weird twist.
Oh No.
You know,
you know,
you get your burger reader in Korea.
We Got Burger Rico.
What it sounds like,
some sounds like some Wisconsin and
that's so tough.
So do they put ketchup in it?
Like my nightmare details.
If it's really dedicated to being a
hamburger.
I have a problem in a Burrito with some
French fries in there.
Probably that's not okay.
There's a lot of them know it's a wrap.
It's a wrap.
Yeah,
it's just her wrap.
If you call it a wrap,
it's much easier for me to handle.
I don't know if I liked it that much.
I was like,
I will not eat that.
You can do it to the mistake and I hated
it.
I hated it,
but I don't think I'm the same way.
I hate it and I'll eat it either.
On the other hand,
I don't like it.
I don't even touch it.
I'll start.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's why we look like I'm actually,
I'm not kidding.
I eat two portions of every meal or like
one and a half.
It's pretty bad.
I ended up starving.
If I.
If it doesn't look perfect to me.
Not that it's not that I want to do it,
I just can't.
Like I can't eat it.
I hear you.
It's just,
you know,
you're built from a different cloth.
I have a problem.
I've my food falling apart and then it's
too messy for me to eat on time.
We're at the restaurant and the waiter
is going by and I'm like,
here give me that.
Like she was all done with their burger
and it was like the whole burger was
still there with all this stuff and I've
had my whole plate is clear.
I'm like,
give me that.
And right when the waiters going,
I'm just taking her whole plate and
start eating it.
And I was just sitting there like I'm
done at.
There's no shame in it could look funny.
You just walked by and was like,
what's going?
Oh my God.
Oh mcn abuse abusive food.
Quarter your time is up.
Giving me a burger.
I'm sure I'd do that for you.
But like I,
I'll,
I,
I can hate an eat so easily.
Like I'll not even like it and it's bad
for me and it's super high calorie.
All fucking eat that shit before you
look blinks.
That's the worst on like this bed with
it tastes bad and it's also bad for you.
That is the worst.
You're just,
you still eat it,
but that's what Disney is all about.
It's like the corn dog,
you know the strange.
Like I think I kicked on a corn dog.
I felt pretty bad about that,
but it's like 2000 cows.
Oh,
let me look up.
How many calories in that weird was the
leg?
No,
I got.
I did get the leg by the way.
Oh,
you got one?
Okay.
This says 400 calories.
I'm here to say that's a fucking
outright.
A lot bullshit.
That is an outright monstrous live.
This corn dog is this size is threader
serving size.
Oh,
that's vendors like five servings.
Okay.
Yeah,
I gotta find out.
I gotta get to the bottom of this.
Can you guys find out what the calories
are important?
That's a monstrous fucking filthy.
Like this big.
Like for anyone who has not had it and
it's deep fried corn.
So awesome.
I feel like that's 1200 calories.
Lee,
do you guys hear about.
There was this megabucks jackpot was
$543,
million bucks.
No Damn.
So this was like a huge Jackpot in
California and I'm 11 employees at one
store all went in together on tickets
and they won.
So basically all of the employees at
this one place are now overnight worth
like 60 million apiece.
That's when I was just thinking like
that place is going out of business,
like everybody's fucking gone.
It's such a funny situation.
It's like this is what it's going to be
like.
That's what it's going to be like this.
But it's funny to think like that.
They're all playing the lottery so they
can never see it
each other ever again.
You know,
these fucking guys,
11 of them
got that article said,
every single one of them said they have
no intention on quitting.
Get Real.
What do they come on?
Like a financial services.
I really love my job as a receptionist.
I'm worth it
a million dollars now and I have no
intention of leaving job as a
receptionist.
People really like going out to work and
it's like,
I know my mom is like that.
Like on Saturday she can't in Israel,
you go back to work on Sunday,
so on Sunday that she can't wait for
Sunday.
Like I've never heard anyone.
Okay.
Say That your family have one day off.
She says,
well,
she always says I can't wait for Sunday.
I want to go
serious.
Yeah.
Different,
different alien race.
What the hell sent you an alien right
there.
You think if your mom wants 29 million
US dollars?
She would work at Delta still.
I feel like she would say that,
but I wouldn't believe it.
No effing way.
These guys,
I think they need to follow up with them
in like two weeks off there be will be
gone after the interview.
Are you kidding me?
What's that?
Check hits the bank.
Twenty $9 billion.
Not what?
Just really financially conservative.
Take it easy.
You got to conserve.
Well,
they have a option.
All 11 of them have this option between
they can receive 18 is this right?
Then $18 million per year.
Oh,
one point.
6 million per year forever or a measly
$29 million pop.
That's crazy.
The one point six,
take the lump.
Take alumni lump all day long.
Because I don't trust.
Take the money and run inflation.
Take the money and run.
I don't want anyone owing me money.
I take the loan every time I win the
lotto.
You know it's funny.
By the way,
I bought a ticket.
I'm not ashamed to admit it.
I bought four tickets.
I dropped $10 on that.
Why did they tons of tickets probably.
They probably pulled in and bought a
bunch,
but think just like for they bought,
they only like a handful of doesn't
achieve bucks.
Spent $10,
bucks a piece.
So 11 people,
so 22 bucks.
They probably had 11.
That's a decent amount.
Oh God,
that's crazy.
Have you guys ever played the lottery?
You ever buy ticket and just fantasize?
What if you were like a billionaire?
Overnight?
I never ever bought him.
Really?
My mom used to always do the same where
she buy,
when the lottery get big,
she'd buy ticket and then for like the
whole week she would just talk about
fantasizing about the ball for the whole
week.
Like I would move to Florida and I would
do with the kitchen this way and like
really extended fantasy,
started getting you excited and file
maybe we are going to win.
My Dad used to own and kiosk and really
I didn't know your dad was a key ops man
and I don't know if you know and that is
here,
like if I got a gun.
So they,
they did a lottery there and I just
remember all the old people going in
there and like placing their bats and
they're so serious about it.
There's like combos and like I'll do the
acs and the ACS Combo and I dunno,
I ain't gonna even know what it means
even though it's completely random.
I know the people that when like they're
doing their exam,
you know,
like they're all,
it's been three days since the seven
weeks.
First number on that.
Can you imagine though that amount of
money to win?
It's so obscene.
Half a billion dollars for literally
doing nothing.
It's hard to say no to that.
That's where the Jackpot is so high
because so many people in bond
overnight,
one of the richest people in the world.
How does that differ from what are
weird?
That's how it works.
They're just.
They make money by people buying tickets
makes the jackpot larger.
It's actually the lawyer always one.
Obviously the lottery,
a lottery every night.
Actually the lotteries,
the interesting thing it was,
I don't remember where I learned about
this,
but it was made to be a public service,
so like it's like a voluntary tax.
Literally that's how they thought about
it and it originated in like Japan and
so you will be like,
give us a book,
have a chance to win a prize,
but the money goes to civic services,
so like they use the lottery money to
fund schools and local shit and that's
still what they do today if you'd like.
The California lottery is a.
is a public fund used for the benefit?
The welfare of the gut?
I don't know why I always thought it
interesting.
It's interesting.
It's so like it's a California state
lottery,
so it's run by the APP.
It.
I think it's the same.
Well because I've seen like you'll see
like an auditorium and it says the.
It's a voluntary tax is literally a
voluntary tax.
Pretty cool.
Growing up,
my dad always would tell me it's the
idiot tax.
That was another word,
but then whenever the Jackpot was huge,
like it was on this one,
he would still go buy a ticket like
that.
Well,
my brother explained it to me,
Mr.
Science.
He goes,
at a certain point when it gets so big,
you're actually statistically
a favorable bet.
You know what I mean?
Let's say you have like a one in 10
million chance of winning and so usually
let's say the price is 5 million bucks
and you buy ticket,
so that's not a statistically good.
Say if you put a dollar and you stand
the win half a billion,
then all the sudden,
yeah,
maybe there's logic there.
You can't win if you don't play Nice.
Yeah.
She didn't want one.
Not No one wins.
Nobody went,
oh,
I have a great video about the lottery.
I want to watch with you guys.
Well,
there's another story I want to talk
about.
Just cracked me up.
Nela,
almond breeze,
almond breeze.
You guys drink almond milk?
Yeah.
Well you'll be.
You'll be horrified to know that it's
being recalled because there's actually
a trace amount of real book in it.
Even like some other day I was.
I had a big old bowl of honey smacks,
like the cereal that I never eat.
I just picked it for some reason.
I'm like,
oh,
I'll have honey smacks.
And then like we're driving home from
Milwaukee.
I'm like this fucking crazy radio
stations.
Like on this goofy hip hop station,
Dj fresh,
fresh,
just recalled honey smacks it.
Has Salmonella and it like what the
fuck?
Like a sub plot from Salmonella funds to
throw and be like,
Oh,
you thought I was going to Salmonella.
No,
but isn't that fucking hilarious?
They're making all men milk a milk
alternative and somehow real milk is
slipping into how the hell does that
happen?
One mission to not have milk,
they're recalling 145,000
half gallons of almond milk because they
could contain actual milk.
Whoops.
Why?
There's no information about why actual
milk got into the almond milk.
I tried to dig into it and just nobody.
Nobody has any excuse.
It's like a great mystery.
I just loved the idea of somebody going
to buy almond milk because they're like
a Vegan or something and there's just a
trace amount of real milk.
It just like a little prankster,
like disgruntled worker.
Just a little milk.
It's like,
that's not like a little mistake.
That's like a fucking like a month of
shit.
How long does that go on?
I Dunno know the recalling a lot of
milk.
And why does the almonds have to pay for
the,
you know,
how many,
how many defenses almonds are going
down.
Jason was freaking out about the cereal.
He thought they were like rubbing raw
chicken on the serialized
cereal.
Cereal wasn't a cook,
but what touch like every piece of the
cereal or like what?
How dirty ass guy at the factory who
probably takes a shit cooks chicken
without washing his hands and he's
handling the smacks just scooping him up
like raw chicken goop in your smacks.
Oh Man.
I have a ton of videos to watch.
Jesus.
We're all over the place.
We talked about our dinner plans.
Oh,
by the way,
thank you for reminding me.
We're killing it.
I think I'll get steaks and we'll order
fucking Mexican food.
Going to be so good.
We've got cookies.
I've got to make cocktails.
So you guys like Moscow Mules?
Yes.
We just got the 10 guts.
It's got breakfast,
breeze
kind.
They're all of a sudden.
Oh,
I'm sorry that I like to put artists in
bread and wake up at five.
Am You Isla?
Sorry that I sound like a hipster while
I'm literally sweating as the sun rises.
Thank Leslie.
As sleep peacefully.
That is really hipster thing.
Speaking of the light was really nice to
wake up and have a fresh cookie.
Have a smell of chocolate chip cookies,
a wharf there up in the bar is going to
expect that.
It's a one day thing.
You guys are the sweetest couple ever.
Do you guys fight about anything ever?
They don't last.
Like what?
Do you guys fight about?
Disagreements?
Like stupid,
stupid stuff.
Yeah,
but then we just like laugh.
Like if we look at it,
if we like make eye contact,
get like woke up like really serious.
I go try to like look at each other,
make
that's really doesn't just let it go and
then it's over.
Excuse me.
That shit.
Yeah.
Maybe if we like separated and like went
in separate rooms or something.
We could have a bigger fight but we
never want to fight more.
We're working on.
We went in.
I like the idea of you guys had a fight.
Like maybe if we.
Jason,
maybe if you went in that room and I go
into.
We could get angry at each other for a
little longer.
Yeah.
Probably not even send each other texts
like I'm hungry.
That's usually when they like,
okay,
I'm hungry.
All right,
let's,
let's squash this.
Beef menial.
Always fight about food.
Pretty much.
Not Anymore.
It used to be all we fought about like
what you're telling her to eat or like
where do you eat?
Because Ila,
I don't know why we argue so much about
it
because like it's hard.
It's hard to tell.
I come from like,
my mom usually cooks all the time,
so growing up I only ate at home so I
ate.
I hate eating outside and
I up the opposite.
Okay.
That's all right.
Ethan ate out like every time all day.
Right.
That's as I understand it the same.
So that is why we would have a lot of
like I wanted to eat out.
Yeah.
You don't like eating out,
you don't have anything else,
but we don't really argue about it and
as much anymore
I've,
I've learned to do at home.
We did our.
No,
I'm kidding there.
Check this out.
Speaking to the lottery story is about a
moment.
It was after barb reddick and her
nephew,
tyrone mcguinness,
picked up their big win.
One point $2,000,000
chase the age Jack Pot,
but it didn't take long for things to
turn sour when both were handed separate
checks for $600,000.
JCA sweeteners is going to court.
I've taken the car.
That was my take was that I bought.
I bought it and now he's trying to say
we split.
I said split with the 50 slash 50 now.
But no chase ca's I've taken them to
court and I'm getting my lawyer
tomorrow.
Both names are on the winning tickets
than a critic says.
We agreed to split the consolation prize
and not the Jackpot.
If the ace was drawn,
I put his name on the thing.
I told them for a good lock.
They always lie,
but I'm taking them to court.
I'm serious.
I'm getting a lawyer tomorrow.
Who's name was tyrone you by the time I
love it.
What is name for good luck and I won.
He works his name work.
Do you got the good life?
Like damn.
Get a little fucking money
instantly to.
You always hear these stories of
families falling apart over this,
but like over the course of neither.
There's not like 30 seconds later
something else is going on with,
but if any,
if it gives them money,
how is he going to enjoy it?
No,
he's out.
He's fucking piece now.
That's 600,000.
What is she,
by the way?
This whole.
I don't know where they live.
Like I assume not anymore expensive.
Like what is this lady going to do with
600,000
bucks and he's gone.
She's gone on to make a plan.
Take your.
Yeah.
For the last 20 years.
Plans to.
I guess you're right.
Redo the kitchen.
Could cost you anywhere.
I thought this was interesting.
Just like a couple bucks.
That's a quick turnaround here.
Why did you do that?
Because he's like a son to me.
He was like,
Shit,
you know,
it's almost like she wishes she didn't
win because then she'd almost rather
that they didn't win and then that they
were still like friends.
Crazy.
Like it's ruined her life.
What are they going to do?
It's like you just won $600,000,
wouldn't you?
Going in and out spend half of it on
attorneys.
God,
he'll get over it on the winning ticket.
They felt the phone number was mckinnis.
Britney's curly says when she called to
notify the winters,
no one answered,
so she called the shape or good.
It doesn't get better.
You got all the good stuff.
I mean,
I've got some other stuff here,
but we really blessed.
We really spent a lot of time on the
food.
I don't have regrets.
Tell me if you want to watch any of this
stuff.
We can wrap it up.
Squash some stuff.
But I've got Christian mom upset by
north north.
Have you seen that by one,
by one with 10.
That's an investment.
Yeah.
It's an audit because I.
It was kind of related to you writing
your own hip hop song.
It shouldn't do it.
I kind of want to say.
Okay,
good.
Alright,
so I'm going to put on the person.
Yeah.
Oh the.
It's a little long.
So bear with me.
The song by Vince staples called North
North on the radio.
By the way,
that's a great song,
but as far as hip hop songs go,
it's really not the worst one.
Not even close,
man.
He's got a message,
right?
So anyway,
she's having like a mental breakdown
that it was playing on the radio and the
best she reads the whole lyrics to the
song with the best part is that because
she literally reads every single lyric,
they were able to mix it up.
So she's singing the song like he sat
there for like 12 minutes reading and
crying and having,
yeah,
it's great
bitch.
You don't die.
I just want to dance with you baby.
Just don't move too fast,
man.
Down shaded.
Take a Nigga mind on that and we
function on my Yankee hat.
Gangster gangster rap shit is
everywhere.
I didn't know the difference.
And Deanna Brown,
like the dope daddy shooting in the
kitchen,
never went to Mali.
Hilson or Cabrillo of Trello.
I don't even know if I pronounced that
right below email.
Then.
That was the first verse.
This is the.
The main chorus says,
I ain't never ran from nothing but the
police.
By the way,
I ain't never ran from nothing but the
bullies.
Staples had the best response.
I thought he was like,
he's like,
he's like your reactions,
right?
That's the point of the song.
It's a good day.
You feel that way because it's so fucked
up.
Like that's right.
You're getting the right reaction.
That's okay.
Right?
We wonder why this society is so messed
up.
Well,
listen to the music.
Hit the corner.
I
don't need to watch all of this.
It's great.
So no,
I can't believe I missed it.
It's got a lot of Scada.
Love Lore surrounding it.
Oh.
So her kids were in the background.
Daughter was like put it on and it was
like on the radio or something back.
Actually the fact that the little babies
behind her,
she's saying it word for word.
It's the same thing.
It's actually a worse on the radio.
You don't really catch all the lyrics.
She's like,
I can't believe my kids are hearing this
on the radio and she's there dropping n
bombs and all this bullshit.
She's invasion new video.
Like people don't really get how it
works.
You know?
All white people.
No don't really good like that.
It's like from a character still trying
to figure out like everything is like
literal,
like it says in the song I shot this
guy,
they think he literally shot the dude,
right?
Yeah.
Like,
oh my God,
the police looking into this.
Totally.
Um,
so we've got to prank invasion,
new video,
moaning addition.
Let's check it out.
Pretty bad stuff.
There was a seizure edition as well.
She's pretty solid as you can imagine.
Theaters crazy.
Yeah.
He's,
he's video since ours are his,
his invasion.
Yeah,
he,
he's off the map pretty much.
I mean he's got kissing my fans,
nurse addition couples edition,
whipped cream addition.
I think moaning addition.
You're gonna you're gonna.
Really enjoy this morning.
And how does it think about it by the
way?
He's,
he's,
he's kissing prank.
He's been working out.
He's like,
yeah,
a lot more veins.
Yeah,
way more.
Raphael.
He's lived up.
Huh?
But like he's more imposing now.
Like if you wanted to rape me or
dominate me.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if he like you're giving him that
fucking kiss but the music never changes
somethings.
But you know what,
when I see these biceps kissing friends
gave me a really weird and creepy way
and see what happens.
As always,
let's do it as always like a really
quick game of rock,
paper,
scissors.
If I win,
I get to give you a really quick hands.
Okay.
Alright,
here we go.
Here you go guys.
No,
at this point it's not just comedy.
Why?
Just to see what happens then it just
stopped.
I don't think he's having like an
epileptic seizure.
Is that what it sounds?
Alright Chris,
don't get my visit to monetize it.
Fucking.
Is it the same noise each time or does
he do differently?
Quick Kiss.
Okay.
Here we go.
Rock,
paper,
scissors.
One more time.
Here we go.
Rock,
paper,
scissors.
I went,
come here.
As always,
I think he's.
He's really just trawling.
Yeah,
he knows I'm not going to laugh.
This is the part that we're me.
Is parodying himself.
Exactly.
We made that one
video,
you know,
a,
a closer look at the line was getting so
blurred that I was actually starting to
enjoy watching his videos because
they're so like the morning one,
like it's your watch it and it's so
stupid,
you know,
like there's a weird transformation
going.
I feel like if he keeps following the
thread of so obscene,
so stupid that he could really be on to
a new wave of entertainment
that's always the hardest.
And somehow he went against all odds to
look back and make the girl in the same
one probably that it's set up that you
know,
just studied.
It's just so repetitive.
Oh,
there's
one here.
Let's watch this last one.
It was fun.
I saw,
I loved it.
Um,
how to stop cyber bullying.
It's a big issue facing all of us today
on the Internet.
As you guys know,
you work on their night live on the
Internet.
Have you guys ever had promised
cyberbullying all the time?
Yeah.
Yeah,
me too.
They're bullying us all day.
Everyday.
Tough.
It was on overwatch and some guy was
yelling at me about something,
right?
Oh,
scared.
What do you do at that point?
You've literally helpless.
I leave.
I leave the house.
I have a hole in my backyard laying when
it gets so well.
Anyway,
we have a helpful tip for you on cyber
bullying.
I think the best advice I would keep
through cyber bullying,
but the way she phrases it almost sounds
like she's going to get tips to the
cyber bullying.
Close your eyes.
I'm sorry.
I would get to sign her bullying.
Nailed it.
That
is great advice.
Yes.
She's getting bullying now.
Ironically.
I think we did it.
Let's go eat some dinner and go love
your mom.
Everyone loves a good advice.
So guys,
thank you for all tuning in and watching
and enjoy the show.
A Dow.
Wow.
Hold it together for another minute.
We're almost done.
Next month is looking pretty good.
Yeah,
sure.
We.
Dan,
what do we got?
We've got jack sat down,
Jack Septic Guy,
uh,
in a couple of weeks and then a dinner
after that.
And then,
uh,
this one's pretty big.
We've got Tim heidecker coming on the
31st.
What am I hiding him?
Really cool.
I had occur.
Yep,
and then the week after that we got a
Adam Carolla,
so Adam Carolla also.
Very cool.
Thank you.
Um,
and possibly,
well I won't say it because it's not
confirmed,
but hey,
we got a great lineup.
Samples.
Yes.
So next fight is probably just as
alright,
next.
Friday's just us having fun with the
soundboards.
You guys are not gonna.
Want to miss it and would that be nice?
Thank you so much for watching.
I hope you have a great weekend.
Love your mother's guys.
Have a great weekend.
Take care of yourself.
Happiness is number one.
You've got to do what's good for you in
your life.
Be Mindful,
be aware of everything that you're
appreciative,
you know,
constantly.
Don't take anything for granted.
Like if I could all go away,
I mean seriously,
you don't,
you don't want to lose sight of that.
I think the audience will like if he
goes,
I ended.
Dan,
save us from ourselves by everybody.